hey I'm John I'm Michael and this is the
gadget lab show and this week we're
going to talk about a new e-reader and a
pebble smartwatch and a huge honkin
speaker but first up the e-reader the
e-reader here it is in all of its glory
this is the new version of the nook
simple touch e-reader so what's the
secret sauce what's the big feature in
this one the big feature of this is that
it has been updated from last year's
model to include a backlight so it has
an LED backlight a lot like the kind
you'd find in like a tablet or phone
that illuminates the screen from behind
and makes it user to read while you're
laying a bit so it's a ink but it's got
the back leg so it's sort of the best of
both worlds sort of the best of both
worlds yes that is that is correct the
screen itself is the same touch
sensitive screen so it finds a noble's
best ereader that you can buy it's their
their flagship ereader and it just you
know has this fancy new feature on it so
so i'm a kindle guy this is the
competitor what about this would compel
me to make the switch well I mean
basically it's the elimination behind
the screen because the regular kindle
the kindle touch i think is like a
hundred dollars for the non 3g version
just for the Wi-Fi version this Wi-Fi
version with the barnes & noble nook
with the illumination is 140 so it's an
extra 40 bucks for the light now what
you could do if you're a Kimble person
is get a kindle with a case with a light
in right in those there's an LED that
sort of swings out yeah look it's sort
of a little cantilevered thing right and
those you know you can get an
aftermarket or from amazon for around 40
to 60 bucks and that's also you'll be
carrying around your kindle in a case
this has a light without the case which
is pretty cool the light is not
necessarily as good as i was expecting
it to be i've been playing around with
it a little bit today and it's it says
that it eliminates the whole it
illuminates the whole screen evenly but
it's a little patchy you can kind of see
that it's bleeding out from the top a
little bit it's a little bit dimmer in
the center that it is along the edges
but you know by a large you can reach
book while you're sitting around in the
dark right that's really all that mad
and so if you're already invested in the
whole barnes and noble universe this
might be the next best step yeah this is
an upgrade for you if you're trying to
decide between the kindle and the the
nook i would i would recommend that you
don't buy advice based on the actual
device itself right that you buy a
device based on the platform that that
device is attached to okay so i'll put
you on the spot platform wise amazon or
B&N i prefer amazon me too i do and
actually i do like their hardware a lot
as well it's not all about the platform
for me with the candle I like the
buttons also the screen mapping on the
kindle for the touch features and the
menus are different than the the barnes
& noble nook but you know i have a
couple of family members who have tried
both and they absolutely love the nook i
think for for a lot of people their
kindle people because the kindle arrived
first but people are making the decision
now a lot of them are picking the nook
so it's still you know kind of a kind of
even and even split they're out there
more the TV commercials they're they're
getting more press there in the public
mind sure yeah and in retail both of the
devices are out there we should also not
forget about the third player the Kobo
touch or should we I don't know hey we
gave them a plug that's about what they
get that's right okay so that is the
latest from barnes & noble next up we're
gonna hear the latest about the pebble
smartwatch
so Alexandra you traveled to Palo Alto
and saw the new pebble smartwatch in
person what what did you see well
basically I saw a prototype of the
SmartWatch they don't have a totally
finished product yet but I did get to
see a working prototype and I even wore
it on my wrist I saw the display which
is kind of all the rage of pebble at
what it's basically what makes pebble
special and it looks really great it's a
memory LCD display so it's kind of like
eating in that you can read it in the
Sun really easily and it actually pops a
lot better than the Sun and it actually
refreshes faster than eating displays
like Kindles take a couple seconds this
is fast right and so it's a smart watch
than was was born from a Kickstarter
project right and they have they already
closed the campaign it hasn't closed yet
but they've completely sold out of the
watches so they've sold a total of
85,000 watches and that's what they
capped at and right now they're about at
10.2 million dollars on Kickstarter so
that's they're still accepting pledges
but and that that 10 million is a record
right it's it's triple the previous
record so what are they going to be
doing with all this money what kind of
new development do they show off well
they showed me a couple partnerships
they recently announced that they are
partners with RunKeeper it's a running
app and then yet today I think they
announced that they are partnering with
twine which was another Kickstarter
campaign it's basically a box that has
Wi-Fi connection and a sensor and you
can use if this then that sort of if
let's say the twine box gets shaked then
it'll send a message to pebble and so
now twine and pebble are in partnership
together and so what kind of real-world
applications could find deliver to this
to this thing living on my wrist
hmm so you could attach twine to let's
say indoor and when someone knocks the
twine will sense that someone's knocking
the door and it can send a message like
somebody's knocking on the door to the
pebble and so even if you don't hear the
door knocking you'll know so very crafty
so it goes way beyond just simply
letting you know when a foam comes into
your smartphone right right what a call
comes right okay so when are we going to
finally see the pebble watches they are
scheduled to ship in September so but
they're only going to ship to the
original Kickstarter backers which
that's 85,000 watches and then after
that people who didn't back them on
Kickstarter can supposedly buy them from
the website got it so I'm going to be
first in line really anticipating this
watch it seems super cool and it seems
to be getting cooler by the day with
with the kind of things we're learning
right okay next up 10 inches of big
audio okay Mike this looks like a very
familiar object yet it's grown larger
somehow yeah it's the big jambox and
guess what it looks just like a jam box
except this bigger much bigger yeah the
original is about 6 inches yeah bye
maybe like 22 and a half something like
that this is a full-time know about 10
inches and about three and a half on the
on the side so it's giant okay so
portable audio yeah everyone wants to
know is it loud yes and does it vibrate
on the table the way the little jam box
does yes but not in in the annoying way
I'll get in a good way okay tell us
about it uh well I mean you know it's
it's a Bluetooth speaker the the jam box
is the most popular bluetooth speaker
you can get out there it's two hundred
dollars for the original it's been out
for about a year and a half and
everybody loves it huge hit big hit at
Apple stores this is the new one it's
300 it is a very very similar in the way
that it works the way that it pairs with
your phone the way you can control it
with just about any Bluetooth device and
of course it looks very much the same it
is way louder and not only
louder because volume is one part of the
equation the other part is clarity right
so it sounds much better it has better
bass in as better trouble it says better
definition all around better stereo
image because the speakers are a little
bit further apart right and the
vibrations the old Jambox dances around
the table and and it knocks off the
table and dies and you know gets all
bent out of shape and everything this
one has these giant rubber feet on the
bottom so it doesn't really move it does
move a little bit or vibrates it uses
the whole table is sort of like a you
know resonant device so you get a little
bit more of like a boom out of it when
you have it on a table versus like on a
marble or on sand or something like that
so yes it does vibrate it'll rattle your
teeth from about four or five inches
away so how large a room can it Phil uh
well it fills actually it feels just
about any room in the house except for
the biggest for yeh but it fills it
fills parlors conservatories bathrooms
antechambers antechambers panic rooms
you can actually get away with a small
jam box in the panic room but you know
the thing that I notice about this
that's that's really cool as it works
way better outside outside so yeah like
on a back door in the back yard or the
beach or something like that because
it's totally wireless it has
rechargeable battery inside runs on
Bluetooth you can just carry it with you
anywhere that you know it's comfortable
to carry something that's kind of big
and bulky weighs about 34 it is it is
big it comes there's an optional
carrying case for it too yeah it kind of
looks like one of those like six or
coolers click it's sort of a neoprene
zip up ring with a handle on it you can
pull out the jam box with a little bit
of drama yeah when you're at the beach
where yeah it's oh yeah packed up it's
about the size of a bottle of wine so
anywhere where you'd feel comfortable
carrying a bottle of wine you can carry
this so you know the park or its
friend's house or I don't know your roof
right for the fireworks and it's it's a
lot heavier than the original but it's
not as heavy as you would think just
from looking at it right right right
yeah actually when when I first picked
it up I reach for with two hands and
kind of it's actually quite comfortable
just carry around
on hand right it is a brick and it is
sort of a beast but it sounds great so
you sacrifice portability but you get
utility so it's it's already been
reviewed on unwired and what did it get
it got a thumbs up or is that trademarks
I I believe I gave it a date out yeah
eight out of ten and I did I did get on
price because 300 bucks is a lot of
cheese to throw it a speaker right but
it's pretty cool it's pretty awesome
everybody out showing two wants one and
they want to know where to get it and
how much and all that so it's the new it
portable speaker yes and it replaces the
old jam box which was the it affordable
speaker and still an excellent speaker I
still recommend that to people okay so
now you have two GM boxes to choose from
four different size applications and
that is it for portable audio this has
been the gadget lab show check us out
next week
you